after two years of delays were mere
weeks away from the launch of the
division ahead of its beta I guess which
is next week is that right yeah there's
a beta supposedly starts on the 28 ok so
i guess ahead of that between more
people getting their hands on us I kind
of really want to know like you get
right down to and sort of talk about
exactly what this game is because it
feels like what the game we filled in
the blanks of what we saw as far back as
e3 2013 as to what this game was like I
remember watching that initial trailer
and thinking oh this is very sort of
like slow and intentional co-op
experience like something like a co-op
ghost recon advanced warfighter
something like that massive fan of all
rainbow six games Ghost Recon stuff like
that kind of felt like that like
everyone's talking and on point and and
the numbers were popping up but it felt
like sort of like a tactical shooter
that was co-op and from what we've heard
over the past week it looks like it's
more like a sort of an online party
shooter where you're you're fighting
waves upon waves of people iron you play
that last week Scott water world has a
great preview up on the site which folks
can't go check out if they want to as
well but I want to talk to you about
what this game is what does it somebody
who plays shooters primarily somebody
loves games like like battlefield and
loves games like Rainbow six siege what
is the division to you when you when you
were literally like shooting people and
playing it so the division it's a co-op
shooter it's more so a co-op shooter
than destiny is I think des a lot of
people compare this game to destiny in
destiny there's people wandering around
the world when you're playing at I would
call it a minimo it's like it's just a
mini MMO like all the human players yeah
I like mini moke music who use that but
like mini mo problems mini mo money no I
guess I so the division is not like that
it really is a co-op shooter you will
only see other players in the first area
that you spawn and then maybe in a
couple other select spaces so you do
have to pull your friends in with you
before you go out into the city okay um
there-there marketing it as an RPG right
now yeah very heavily it seems like
actually it's almost like they're there
they've realized people don't think it's
not an RPG and they're sort of well I
guess whatever we or we'll get into what
RPG means for a game like the division
but sorry go on yeah so it took destiny
I think it took destiny a took Bungie a
good year
realize that it was they thought they
had a shooter of what they really had
was a shooter RPG so for the division
they're coming at it from the other side
they're saying we have an RPG and the
shooting is kind of a byproduct of that
and I'm not sure which came first
whether like the sort of me do I don't
know it's mediocre it's just okay
shooting it's right the shooting doesn't
feel fantastic it gets the job done and
it complements the world which i think
is very well fleshed out and you have a
very good sense of time in place in the
division it feels like the pandemic
happened all the weak people died off
and like you're right at that limb rooms
yeah you can run fast enough all died it
feels like you're at that moment right
where people are like running out of
their supplies right and they're getting
desperate in these three factions the
rikers looters and cleaners are all kind
of at their height of power that's when
you come into it now what you're
actually doing in the world I think it's
going to depend on whether you like RPG
or shooters more right the shooting
itself and the cover system is very I
found it to be very in precise I love
another ubisoft game Ghost Recon
phantoms which is another cover base
shooter and that you run you can knee
slide you can prone slide you can get in
cover and you can have three different
standing kneeling or prone you have none
of that control in this game okay all
you really have our gears of war dive
roll a Gears of War roadie run to cover
and then the the game itself handles how
your character behaves in cover rice and
then it's by teaching you say that
because when I think about what made you
know destiny such a great game to play
regardless of its the you know live near
problems at how to launch and then a lot
of which were fixed last year eventually
was that it's a it's a bungee shooter
like yeah just do shooting real good so
to hear you say that like shooting a
movement doesn't feel particularly great
is a little bit yeah really but on the
other hand this has much deeper RPG
mechanics which is kind of what their
advertising so you have three sets you
have like three skill trees that are
going at all times you have your
abilities which you have three of them
and you have no limitations you can pick
from any skill tree then you have
basically the equivalent of active
skills and you have passive skills so
you're gonna find a lot of people doing
stats tweaking you can craft items you
can build very specific characters but
you're not you're not locked into them
like if something doesn't work you just
back out and go another direction are
you leveling off that one character and
sort of unlocking better loose as you go
along or is it feel more like you're
doing higher level missions and then
through those missions you're finding
better you find better loot through
higher level missions there's a little
bit of a disparity with like a level one
I kind of had the same thing I found
with destiny like a level one gun
against the level in character didn't
really feel that different from a level
20 gonna let with a lot of 20 character
right cuz we played both a starting
character in a level 20 character the
game didn't feel like it had changed
that much but you know I didn't get to
experience the journey in the storyline
that happens in between 1 and 20 so
again mechanically I thought the game
was competent it's not the thing that's
gonna carry it like destiny it sounds
like it did as opposed to destiny which
I remember Kevin's review back in i
guess it was late 2014 at this age was
one of the biggest things he said Peter
was that it was a game that was sort of
bereft of place like I'm we've
subsequently founded that the story had
actually been ripped out of the game and
do you think that's important to it to a
co-op like shooter like this does that
didn't matter and detonate it didn't
really feel fleshed out and do you think
it could be to the benefit of a game
like the division because you know maybe
maybe that's what people like to make
games like borderlands I don't know I
think it really matters and you look at
something like destiny that's set and
sort of like these alien worlds it's
easy to like I say easy real you know
and very limited terms but it's easy to
sort of concoct ease fantastical things
that don't exist right and just your
imagination and say this is what the
world is yep the division you know it's
using Manhattan right like people know
Manhattan every time yeah yeah so I
think it's important in the sense that
it's grounding the game in something
that we can relate to and as you made it
sound they actually do a good job of
that which I I think that's important
for any game to do is to to draw you
into the world um you know or else it is
just about mechanics yeah but a game
needs a little bit of soul I think
that's why people gravitated towards
when they saw the e3 2013 stuff was that
all just like look this like feels
different because it's like oh it's
contemporary and it feels like it's
grand and it feels like I can reach
and sort of touch it like yeah a lot of
his games come for me like growing up
with harsh winters like in around New
York yeah like for me it was like cool
like I could I could see this happening
sort of like if this [ __ ] hit the fan
like oh yeah like I was like I want to
be I want to experience that because
I've walked those streets to see them
empty but then like there's a dude
headlined a card or like waiting to take
you out like I bill is good to me and so
I think it's important in that regard um
the gameplay like I have so many
questions and it's not so much about
what it does or doesn't have but it's
just how it feels mmm that's that's the
one thing I really won't get let me
there's a couple of questions are coming
in from the twitch out in a couple of
already bank to sort of torch on notch
and if I don't get ran to it feel free
to throw your own items as well but a
lot of people are asking a lot of
questions about it feels like you've
sort of tempered your expectation and
that's the conversation we're having
whereas the internet is very much like
is this is this what I think it was so
some of those questions are Don was
rocked occurring a lot of what people
are saying in the Twitter right now
impressions on whether or not enemies
are a bit bullet spongy that's one of
the things that came across in the
gameplay was man you were shooting a guy
in a head alaj he doesn't really seem
like he's reacting in a realistic way
you know I saw a clip where there was
five or six just hooded people wandering
towards you knew not taking cover and
soaking up bullets like it's going out
of fashion it is that the experience of
playing the division I would have two
things to say about that and I think one
it's a double-edged sword because it's
contemporary setting you're not shooting
aliens or like you know locus or
something huge that feels like it could
take a lot of bullets right so it is a
little weird when you're pumping a dude
with a hoodie fool around and he's not
reacting at all yeah and I think a lot
of a lot of the disparity between what
I'd like the shooting to be and what it
is came down to just the enemies not
reacting very present rights like they
don't seem aware that they're getting
shot a lot of times and they don't react
like they're getting shot and I think
those are potentially fixable things on
the other hand I will say that the
preview build that we all played
including youtubers and everybody who
was there yeah was three people playing
and the game we were told scales to
difficulty so I do wonder i think a lot
more people are going to be playing this
is a single player experience then
people think because you won't run into
other people randomly in the world
outside of the spawn zone that's an inch
in question O'Connell
squat will this game offer to someone
who's playing solo could you play
because that's the mid the main reason I
dropped off destiny was I I got what I
think I'm super low like another 15 or
16 or something and I just thought oh
god I'm really feel like my experience
being handicapped because I'm not
playing other people so is this again do
you think you could play solo the
question is how well does a game scale
to a solo player we didn't see that it
was very hard with three people and I
will say that the the challenge was
there for three people and you will
probably have to work with your friends
if they do the same thing and to an
individual I don't see how you would
survive on Normal difficulty hmm but
again we didn't get to see the game
scale down to a single person but yeah
like that was one of the reasons why I
taper off destiny over time too and you
know I would come back to it as my
friends came back to it and then taper
off as they taper down yeah whereas this
game you know endgame content aside
that's a whole other discussion it
probably will be a little bit more
friendly to an individual person she's
probably a lot more friendly to an
individual person anyways I guess yeah
dog some of those problems critical
reviews asks is it pretty easy to group
up with friends and then Bob Jones I
needed an 80 asking a question a lot of
people in the chatter and Max party size
so it wasn't easy to get involved other
people and what was it was it for as a
max yeah four players co-op and I think
in the in the zone you spawn it was
pretty easy i can't remember it was just
a couple button presses after writing at
somebody or somebody on your friends
list it's a little bit disappointing
that you're not going to just run into
people out in the world because i always
liked that about kind of just
organically meeting up with people to
share a moment and then dissipating and
you won't get that outside of the dark
zone but there is the dark zone yeah
we'll say that the dark zone is probably
more true to their original vision than
any other aspect of this game it feels
like kind of the Daisy meets I don't it
sounds like an instance like a
multiplayer instance or something where
your current well actually I guess the
opposite of what it instances in that
it's like you're booting into like an
area where you can run into random
people I mean it looks like what they
showed three 2013 at least not to keep
holding the game accountable to its rear
vision but like that's that's what I
wanted to play right that's what I think
people in the chat
it's a play and I think that's where
people are all going to end up to as a
matter of fact I think you're going to
want to get there as early as possible
because I don't know how they're going
to STATS balance um or whether they're
going to stat balance at all for weapons
like I don't know if a bunch of level
20s are just gonna dominate or rush
these are going to dominate that area so
if a feeling a lot of people are gonna
check out the open world and then
depending on how gated it is because
there are gates their gates with virus
masks right and there are 20 mask over
above our only yeah how big was the
dachshund it was a he was almost a third
of the map ok ok actually and then that
goes into question a lot of people
coffee Jesus and the twitch chat asking
do you think he was off snapping
Brooklyn off the division smacks of
Destiny trying to make more money from
the game later and I guess echoing what
mr. mazique said can you compare the
divisions map size to another games we
have some sort of perspective how big is
this game I do you think it can still be
playable at the size it is now or still
worthwhile the unanswered question so
the short answer is if I just had to
just freakin snowball it I would say
it's about the size of destiny without
loading screens so if you just took all
the planets in the original destiny and
smoosh them together that's what kind of
feels the move loading screens yeah it's
comparable to that size we spent three
hours in just one like I don't know ten
square block area and doing missions and
stuff so it's sizable you know the
density of content is really what
matters yeah and also because it's in a
city with skyscrapers we have no idea
what kind of verticality the game will
have right yeah it's three dimensions so
like we know there's an underground I
don't know if there's any skyscrapers
that you can go into um so yeah it's a
three-dimensional map and we just don't
know how much of that space they're
using but it didn't feel like this was a
game that would be critically hampered
from having Brooklyn off the map or
having let's just say an extra fifty
percent or hundreds and more mapping it
didn't feel like it was sort of
substantial if you I know it's a super
dick wet cuz I'm asking you all for
three our demo to [ __ ] tell me o
helping the game is but i'm not i'm not
very concerned about map size i guess if
you're coming is like a Skyrim player
like no you're not getting you're not
getting anything like that um again I
think you're worried what you're
actually worried when you ask that
question is about content density yeah
and whether there's enough for you to do
in the world yeah the quail is asking
can you see division having any
longevity problem so I guess that's
probably the longevity right now the
only proposed longevity I can see is in
the dark zone whether the dark zone ends
up being like daisy or whether the dark
zone ends up just being generic like pvp
right yep we don't know yet and that's
where the best loot is that's where all
the high level players are going if you
hit level 30 they actually have like a
dedicated dark zone for the highest
level player gclub yeah um I am
concerned though I don't know how match
Megan's gonna work in the dark zone and
if you start this game a week late like
I don't know if a bunch of level 20s are
just gonna stop you right the second you
get in there yeah and I don't know if
you can wander it solo because if I got
three guys and you're by yourself with
some sick loot I'm just gonna take you
out yeah no motivation to not do that
yeah pick them off easy at Peter you got
any questions from you get that sweet
hat no embeds division I feel like for
any of us to like you were kind of
pointing out to really like speak about
this game in definite terms we have to
play it for a long amount of time and
that's just what I want to do i I just
wouldn't gonna play it yeah I guess I
yeah as somebody who has at least had
like a smidgen of what that experience
is the role Akutan forward to it how did
you feel coming away from having some
time with the division did you feel
disappointed did you feel like you had
to reset your expectation did you feel
like it was fun in a different way well
yeah what did you think I think actually
a arte in our office put it best where
he always does yeah the expectation kind
of tanked after last year's e3 right so
my expectations were properly lowered
going into this mmm I think I see a fun
game I didn't see a like it's in the
three hours he played it wasn't
fantastic it was totally competent I
could see having a lot of fun grouping
up with friends and playing through and
I did see some like in the echo
sequences I actually did see some
genuine
really good writing made with the the
Rikers prisoners there was a great
moment where one of them was like
torturing a guard in the cart system
like you know dude I'm not just a number
I'm not just a uniform I'm a guy in the
Rikers guard the Rikers guys has them
great well now you know how I feel huh
so like there were some good moments
like that but there are also moments
where some of the main characters were
kind of like cheese ball on it is Dan
Reicher taking prison same thing so yeah
vision three hours with it it was good
but not great and I'm looking forward to
digging much deeper into this game and
seeing what the deeper content is yeah
it's a pretty soon first week of marches
all right yeah I margate marjay is the
unofficial right now okay give me visual
when is the mobile companion app hahaha
I'm not even cut I do oh god oh my so I
want to get that drone to come in just
like you did range is a super loud acyl
would gone on it have you seen videos of
them trying to but guns on drugs you see
that it's so good it's just like
nightmare murica there you go yeah the
division probably has the tech iron
Samson thank you so much for coming in
telling us all about your time with the
division yeah really appreciate your
time you folks you're watching this life
thank you so much by the way for
supplying us with questions for you guys
watching this on gamespot or YouTube
after the fact and you have any
questions by all means feel free to put
them in the comments below we'll try and
get to them and let us know you think
about the division are you excited for
it are you standing your expectation but
your thoughts in the comments below